i thought it couldn't get any better
i thought
that the elon musk takeover could not
get any more delightful and then
and then politico reported
that it made twitter's top lawyer cry
cry and i love that i think that is just
terrific
the viaja gaddy is in charge of
twitter's
trust and safety legal and public policy
functions she is reportedly considered
the quote moral authority
at twitter she's the executive in charge
of banning dangerous speech
she's the person credited with banning
president trump
she is the person who reportedly took it
upon herself to kick the duly elected
sitting president of the united states
out of the public square in our
allegedly constitutional republic
because she's a big lib and didn't like
what he said
this woman
this woman an actual threat to our
republican system of government
cried
because elon musk said that he was going
to let conservatives speak freely again
and i
love that
i would prefer that my opponents not cry
i would prefer that they come to their
senses and cut out all of their devious
schemes and tricks and see things the
right way
but if they're not going to do that if
they are going to insist on screwing up
our country and upending our traditions
and gobbling up all the power for
themselves illegitimately then i do want
them to cry i want them to cry a
corrective cry like a little baby cries
a corrective cry when he's done
something wrong and mommy and daddy they
don't want to hear him cry but they got
to let him cry it out so that he learns
his lesson
okay that's how i want the lips to cry i
don't want them to cry without reason
by the way a lot of conservatives right
now
are laughing because they say that the
libs are wailing over this elon musk
takeover for no reason that's not true
the libs have plenty of reason to cry
and that is a good thing
if they're if they're going to cry i
want them to cry with good reason i want
them to cry because we have beaten them
at something and a bad thing that they
have tried to do and have done
successfully they can do no longer for
the past several years the libs have
insisted that they are not wielding big
tech platforms as a political cudgel to
silence the opposition and censor us all
into submission they have said it's all
in our heads
the de-platforming the shadow banning
the censoring of stories critical of joe
biden weeks before the presidential
election it's all in your heads it's not
happening don't believe your lying eyes
well
if it's all in our heads
then why are you so upset that the new
owner of twitter is promising to undo
all of that
is promising free speech for
conservatives conservatives are not
reveling in this week's leftist tears
merely because to quote conan the
barbarian
what is best in life is to crush your
enemies see them driven before you and
to hear the lamentation of their women
that is also very fun but the reason
that we are at least the reason that i
am reveling in the leftist tears this
week
is because every one of those tears is
an admission that we were right all
along about how the libs were censoring
us
and and that there is now strong reason
to believe that they are not going to
get away with it any longer i'm michael
nolsus the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from play by ear
who says there is a pretty good argument
for those losing their minds over the
twitter thing i've heard it somewhere
before but if they don't like it they
can create their own platform that's
true go buy your own twitter come on
livs go buy your own twitter i really
like that comment because pointing out
there there is a good argument there's a
good argument for them to cry we can
throw their argument back in their face
and we can clear the air out of after
all this gaslighting after all this
deception
we can clear the air and see what is
really going on when you want to know
what's really going on not just
on twitter but in your home you got to
check out ring right now head over to
ring.com
knowles you know about rings video
doorbell i've told you about it for five
six years now probably you can see and
speak to whoever is at your door whether
you're in the house whether you're at
your office whether you're on a beach on
the other side of the world you know
about rings award-winning home security
system ring alarm i've told you about
that
now you got to go pro you got to go pro
because what ring realized something
that as far as i can tell no other
security company realized ring realized
that you live your life in the physical
world so you got to protect the physical
world your windows and your doors and
all that but you also live a lot of your
life increasingly so in the digital
world so you got to protect your digital
world too so the ring alarm pro will
protect your wi-fi router as well so
you're protecting your data you're
protecting your family and your stuff
not just from the bad guys but from
freeze fire flood it's phenomenal go do
it be like me become a pro you may not
have known it but rings got that
professional monitoring that you can use
so head on over right now to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com
knowles
whenever the left loses an argument
whenever the left gets found out one of
their devious schemes and tricks what's
the first thing they do when they have
nothing left to to legitimately argue
they accuse their opponents of racism
when ann coulter told me this when i was
a college student when a leftist calls
you a racist you know that you've won
the argument
sonny hostin who is one of the minor
characters over at the view
she
launched this argument just yesterday
she said
that
elon musk's takeover of twitter
all it's really about
is about giving
special treatment to straight white men
on twitter it is predominantly
straight white men so when elon musk
says wow this is about free speech it
seems to me that it's about free speech
of straight
white men and so let them have it let
them just go at it i enjoyed the block
button on twitter um i think it has a
real outsized influence in our world
because politicians and celebrities are
on it
now i think this is no way to talk about
elon musk the most prominent
african-american in the world i mean
that's the first incoherence that we
have
i think the claim that she's making is
not true
white men not even straight white men
just white men in general are something
like what 30 of america
and significantly less than 30 of the
world population so i just don't think
it's and then how many of them are
straight i don't so
i just don't think it's true that the
majority of twitter users are straight
white men
but let's say that they were
sunny hostin is act she's saying
the quiet part out loud i guess she's
saying i don't want straight white men
to be able to speak i want other groups
to be able to speak but i don't like
straight white men i i want to censor
straight white men i don't want them to
have a voice in our republic
well too bad lady
i say this as a straight swarthy man
a straight slightly tan man
we're gonna speak we're gonna speak and
i'm sorry that that bothers you i'm
sorry that you don't like straight white
men i'm sorry that you wanna ostracize
us and kick us out of society but we're
not gonna do it we're not i'm sorry
we're not gonna go along with that we're
going to speak we're going to say our
mind and
if you don't like it that's to take it
up with the african-americans new owner
of twitter because we're we're not going
to we're not going to put up with that
kind of stuff we're not we're not going
to put up with a new radical caste
system it foisted upon us by the the
woke lunatics that say that if you're
if you're not what if you're not lgbt
if you're
not a woman or any of the other 75
genders that aren't man
if you're
if you're not
a poc
then you're not allowed to speak we're
not going to do that i'm already
exercising my newfound freedom of speech
on twitter
i just was sending out some test tweets
the other day to test the algorithm i
pointed out
various things such as transgenderism is
not a real category of being
that's obviously true i pointed out on
twitter that ivermectin is a wonder drug
and everyone called it a wonder drug
until a couple of years ago when it
became a political cudgel and the left
denied that
and then
then i pointed out
something that i think is obvious
i said the 2020 presidential election
was obviously rigged
good news is none of those tweets were
taken down they're not being suppressed
we're seeing lots of extra engagement
for conservatives
but some people got very upset at my
free speech
that would be the new york times the new
york times
took issue
with your beloved host
on twitter conservatives celebrate and
progressives cringe about musk's
ownership of twitter
uh when elon musk reached a deal to buy
twitter on monday he promised uh to
return free speech and debate to the
platform saying it was the bedrock of a
functioning democracy
and then just a few paragraphs later we
have
this this quote they say
oh here it is michael knowles a
conservative podcaster repeated on
monday the false claim that the 2020
presidential election was obviously
rigged receiving more than 70 000 likes
now
i agree in principle with the new york
times here we cannot allow this kind of
dangerous misinformation to be allowed
on on twitter
we can't tolerate that okay we cannot
tolerate the new york times spreading
dangerous misinformation because they
say that my claim is a false claim but
my claim is not a false claim my claim
is an obviously true claim the 2020
presidential election was rigged they
rigged the whole damn thing it's just
it's so obvious
twitter specifically rigged it actually
because twitter in the weeks before the
presidential election
censored
damning and damaging information about
the biden family about corruption
because of hunter biden's laptop it was
a story broken by the new york post and
twitter shut it down you couldn't even
privately message it forget about
publicly post it facebook did the same
thing google did the same thing and then
a poll taken after the election said
that 12 of biden voters would not have
voted for him if they had seen that news
story
so they themselves rigged it first of
all
and then they all admitted that it was a
true story a year later
we know that the democrat operatives
rigged the election by changing all the
election rules in the weeks and months
right beforehand we know that in
pennsylvania they they violated the
state constitution we now have a ruling
to that effect that they violated the
state constitution by pushing widespread
mail in ballots you would have to be so
stupid or so dishonest i'm not sure
which it is at the new york times i lean
more toward the latter but it might be
the former you would have to be
unfathomably stupid or ignorant to
pretend that that were not the case so
i'm you have my solemn vow i have not
talked to mr musk he has not approached
me yet if i am named ceo of twitter
then i will ban the new york times
before i finish my hr orientation you
have my promise because because look i'm
all for free speech okay but i agree
with the libs and i agree with many
conservatives and i agree with elon musk
that there are limits we need to have
some basic limits here some basic
standards and the new york times has
obviously fallen afoul of that
the new york times is one of the
biggest purveyors of misinformation in
this country look at the new york times
bestseller list a certain book called
speechless about this very topic written
by yours truly that came out last year
was the number one best-selling book in
the country by a country mile it outsold
the number one on the new york times
list by 40
without bulk buys without any
shenanigans and the times didn't seem to
know my name the times only knows my
name when they want to attack me so i
think look i think it's just really
really important that we stop this kind
of misinformation and as we we
reconfigure the limits
to to speech and moderation and all
these things i think we've got to uh
throw out the times i think it's very
it's important it's important for our
functioning
democracy
when you want to protect not just your
country from but you're also your home
you've got to check out american home
shield right now go to
ahs.com
knowles you're going to thank me later
because no one likes to think about
household breakdowns they happen but you
don't want to think about it they happen
a lot more often than you want to admit
that is why it pays to have a plan from
american home shield to help cover the
cost to repair and replace things such
as your heating system your ac your
fridge
okay american home shield knows that no
two homes are the same that's why
they've got new options to help you find
just the right coverage if american home
shield cannot repair the covered item
they'll just replace it american home
shield members get more more coverage
options fewer exclusions whether we're
talking hvac systems and plumbing to
kitchen appliances their plans help
protect parts of up to 23 essential home
systems and appliances electronics
coverage is available for an unlimited
number of eligible items such as smart
watches flat screen tvs and more you've
roof leak repair pool spa coverage they
have pretty much everything and right
now you can get 50 off their most
comprehensive plans ever by going to
ahs.com
knowles head on over there right now say
50 bucks ahs.com knowles 50 off any plan
service fees limitations and exclusions
apply c plan for details american home
shield be sure with the shield
speaking of election rigging
there's a host on msnbc ari melber
who
he went on a rant on his fears and the
the liberals fears of about the musk
takeover of twitter that
i cannot believe was anything but
parody i cannot believe that this man
and that the liberals are so
unself-aware so oblivious to their own
tactics that they would make this
argument earnestly
if you own all of twitter or facebook or
what have you
you don't have to explain yourself you
don't even have to be transparent you
could secretly ban
one party's candidate or all of its
candidates
all of its nominees or you could just
secretly turn down the reach of their
stuff and turn up the reach of something
else and the rest of us might not even
find out about it till after the
election
elon musk says this is all to help
people because he is just a free speech
philosophically clear open-minded helper
by golly if if the conservatives get
control of twitter they might do exactly
what we have actually done for years
that's the argument he's making i i
don't know that he's being sincere here
again it's this argument of are these
people just extremely stupid or
extremely dishonest and i tend to think
when you think of the new york times
generally the people who work at the new
york times have a pretty high iq they've
had a at least a relatively elite
education
and so i assume they're just very
dishonest rather than very stupid with
msnbc i don't know it's anybody's
guess if if he's self-aware here if he
knows that he is just describing exactly
what the liberals have been doing for
years
then good on him this is a pretty funny
way to subvert the medium but i don't
think that's what he's doing i think i
think he actually doesn't get it
if if some if a small group of people
own the means of communication in a
republic why they could use that to ban
a political candidate oh you mean like
the duly elected sitting president you
mean donald trump while he was actually
the president of the united states they
could just kick him out of the public
square you don't say
they could turn down the reach of
certain users and up the reach of others
oh you mean like shadow banning or
outright d platforming there has been
something that's going on since the news
of the musk announcement came out which
is that conservative accounts are
exploding on twitter and liberal
accounts there are even reports that
they're losing followers i've gained
i think 50 000 followers in the last two
or three days i don't know what that is
that could be
that could be a good thing it could be
that they've taken their their thumbs
off the scales on twitter and they're
actually allowing greater free speech
now out of fear of what's going on
and that musk could come in and find all
of these nefarious dealings they could
be just shredding documents at the
twitter hq and letting their thumb off
the scales or
they could jeremy boring made this point
the god king of the daily wire they
could be attempting to sabotage elon
musk by flooding it with bots or
something i tend to think it's more the
former only because
since this news came out i'm getting a
ton more engagement not just with random
anonymous accounts but with big blue
checkmark accounts
i i tend to think this is more having to
do with
twitter
stopping the censorship and stopping the
shadow banning and stopping the
manipulation of the algorithm
stopping doing the things that this
msnbc host is so afraid the republicans
might do hypothetically or the
conservatives might do hypothetically or
just this eccentric billionaire who i'm
not even sure is a conservative might do
hypothetically
this
this is so delightful
this is just
so
absolutely delightful look at senator ed
markey senator ed markey is a democrat
he tweeted out yesterday quote elon musk
and a handful of billionaires now have
dangerous influence over the most
powerful online platforms that can't be
trusted and self-regulation has failed
we must pass laws to protect privacy and
promote algorithmic justice that's a new
one for internet users especially for
kids
hey ed
where were you a week ago
or six months ago or a year ago or two
years ago
when we were raising all of these issues
oh you loved it because it was your guys
who were controlling it it was your
small handful of liberal oligarchs who
were controlling that
and manipulating the algorithm and
manipulating the elections and rigging
the 2020 presidential election let's
just call it like we see it
but now
now that
a guy who just isn't a leftist is
controlling just one of the platforms
and the smallest platform at that now we
need to send in the marines now we've
got a really really big problem
algorithmic justice
what a stupid phrase
we hear about algorithmic justice
economic justice reproductive justice
was a phrase coined by
failed presidential candidate julian
castro to refer to the justice to kill
babies or something
justice is justice
justice is the persistent will to give
to everyone what he is due
okay that's what justice is and it it
reveals itself
in every aspect of society in every
aspect of our lives
and
we've seen a perversion of justice
by the left in every aspect of we talk
about the leftist perversion of criminal
justice
the real version of justice is punish
criminals and protect victims the
leftist version of justice is
ignore victims and let criminals off the
hook
algorithmic justice according to
conservatives is
within the bounds of the law let people
see the news that they want to see
let people say the things that they want
to say again within the bounds of the
law not saying they can break the law
but within the bounds of that
don't censor people to tilt the scales
for one political party over another
that's justice what he means by
algorithmic justice is just injustice
that's all he's talking about
this is a great perspective on free
speech from elon musk every day that
musk drips more information about what
he's thinking for about the future of
twitter the better i feel about it
musk tweeted out he said the extreme
anti-body reaction from those who fear
free speech says it all but what does he
mean by free speech well he explains he
says
by free speech i simply mean that which
matches the law i am against censorship
that goes far beyond the law if people
want less free speech they will ask
government to pass laws to that effect
therefore going beyond the law is
contrary to the will of the people this
is basically a good explanation of free
speech
you know i wrote this book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
completely snubbed by the new york times
but still number one national bestseller
coming out in paperback in a month or
two
my argument there is not an argument for
free speech absolutism i know a lot of
conservatives make that argument that's
not what i'm arguing i think that's a
historical i don't think that has
anything to do with the founding era or
the actual history of free speech in our
country or anywhere else for that matter
there are always going to be limits the
question is what are those limits what
are those standards
we have had plenty of them in american
history uh standards against obscenity
standards against direct threats against
fighting words a lot of those have been
watered down by lunatic radical
politicians and judges over the past 30
40 50 years
but
what elon is saying is look we in the
political community set the bounds of
speech and then the these extremely
influential social media platforms which
control the flow of information around
our public square they need to abide by
the law and they they really shouldn't
go much further than that there was a
good piece yesterday in compact magazine
by curtis yarvin over what the future of
twitter looks like
twitter does have to engage in certain
moderation
what what do they mean by moderation
well there's moderation
there's
they've got to protect they've got they
do engage in some censorship
they have got to curate certain feeds
they've got to recommend certain things
i mean this just goes with a social
platform
the problem with the moderation
practices of twitter is not that they're
moderating things it's that they're
secretly censoring things and calling it
moderation jarvan has a great
description of the difference between
censorship and moderation
moderation is preventing you from seeing
things you don't want to see
censorship is preventing you from seeing
things that you do want to see
that's the difference any platform any
civilized institution is going to have
some moderation
when we're hanging out in mixed company
i don't think that we should talk like
sailors i don't think it's right to use
that sort of language around women for
instance or
i don't think it's right if you're on a
nice wholesome platform to have porn
everywhere i don't want to see porn all
over twitter i hope they moderate that i
don't i don't think we should have
uh snuff films on twitter right that
would that would be just enforcing the
law you've got to enforce the law
but what you need is transparency and
what you need is everyone to know the
rules and you need the political
community to be able to set those rules
and the fact that elon musk gets it is
so terrific
what's funny is they're talking about
elon's takeover as though it's going to
get rid of all the rules on twitter that
was brian stelter's stupid point two
days ago he said does anyone want to go
to a party where there are no rules no
that's not what we're talking about here
in fact when it gets down to the
real nuts and bolts
proposals concrete proposals that elon
musk has made for twitter
the only thing he's proposed is actually
tightening up speech restrictions he's
saying we have to get rid of anonymous
accounts he's saying we need to get rid
of the bots he's saying we need to have
a little more accountability we need
people to verify their identity
he's not just talking about opening the
floodgates
he's saying no we've got to get a handle
on this and bring it more in line with
the american law and the american
tradition and stop booting half the
country out of the public square
absolutely the right thing to do
now one way to protect your political
community especially during
hyperinflation
is to go look at birch gold right now
text knolls to 98 98 98 do not miss a
second do it right now inflation is
spiking it's at seven percent thanks to
joe biden's policies the paper money in
your wallet is losing value fast and
russia's invasion of ukraine
has worsened the market's decline today
an ounce of gold is worth nineteen
hundred dollars it was worth about three
hundred dollars an ounce in two thousand
i have been telling you for years
you can buy gold from birch gold the
guys that i trust it's your hedge
against inflation well did you know
there's another way to hedge against
inflation you can get silver from birch
gold silver is also considered real
money historically speaking it is
extremely undervalued right now it's an
industrial metal that is in high demand
for everything from electric cars to
solar panels demand is only going to
rise and some analysts say that there is
an unusual dislocation in price that may
present very real opportunities for
silver to rally over the next two years
regardless silver like gold is never
going to zero the american dollar well
it's currently going into the toilet so
you've got to call birch gold they're
the only company i trust do not wait
start diversifying text knowles k w l e
s to 98 98 98 to get a free info kit on
buying gold or silver in a tax sheltered
account no obligation to get this info
text knowles to 98 98.98 to get your
free info kit now
and if you have not signed up for bench
bureau's third thursday book club yet
now's the time to do it it's streams
tomorrow night ben will be discussing
the once in future king by t h white the
book club will stream at 8 pm eastern
and you will get to go through ben's
notes and have your most pressing
questions answered after the stream make
sure you pick up moby dick by herman
melville for next month's book club
check out the trailer
i want to tell you about my third
thursday book club this is not your
average book club these are the greatest
books in the history of western
literature
we're going to dive into the greatest
works of all time these are the books
that helped form the key pillars of
western civilization and helped define
america and we're going to do it live
with thousands of you our daily wire
members
i'm gonna be your personal guide i've
read every one of these books i'm gonna
draw out the important lessons and
themes from every book plus i'm gonna be
answering your questions along the way
so we actually do read the book together
you join the book club you are going to
get smarter you're going to get more
knowledgeable because this is an
investment in your most valuable asset
your mind the third thursday book club
it's going to change the way you think
when you sign up you also get ben's
notes which is a cheat sheet to the
important lessons of this book so sign
up thursdaybookclub.com to get ben's
notes sent straight to your inbox for
the once in future king by t h white
we'll be right back with a lot more
for the past couple of years it's been
tricky to find information about joe
biden's corruption because sometimes our
social media oligarchs just outright
censor it a lot of times it's suppressed
it's hard to find it
got one number for you
5.2 million
5.2
million dollars that is the discrepancy
on joe biden's financial reports
joe biden always styled himself the
poorest member of the senate he that
guy's been in politics his whole life
he's just been taking a government
salary his whole life that's why he's
not a millionaire like his
counterparts in the senate
now joe biden very much is a millionaire
and he's made money from his government
salary he's made money from books he's
made money from speeches okay
but there's 5.2 million dollars
that have gone unaccounted for
we only know about this because of
hunter biden's laptop which the
oligarchic media suppressed the i'm
talking about the establishment news
media and i'm talking about the social
media they suppressed that information
but we got it anyway
and when you look down at
some of hunter's spreadsheets of his
financial
affairs
you'll notice that there is 28 000 in
legal fees for the restructuring of
hunter biden's joint venture with the
chinese communist party controlled bank
of china
28 000 in legal fees uh these legal fees
were paid by joe biden
now
why would joe biden pay hunter's legal
fees well maybe he's just a good father
i thought hunter biden had plenty of
money i think in one of his videos where
he's talking with a hooker and was
recording himself for some creepy reason
he talked about how he made about a
gazillion dollars a year so you think
hunter could pay his own legal fees but
he didn't joe apparently paid some of
his legal fees and why would that be
well because other documents in the
hunter biden laptop suggest that joe
biden was making money off of hunter's
business transactions hunter's business
transactions that were peddling his
father's influence in the government
with hostile foreign powers
with some that are not hostile or we've
had a strange relationship with like
ukraine but some that are hostile
foreign powers like china
and then you look at the discrepancy on
biden's financial reports
daily mail's analysis of this
shows 5.2 million dollars in unexplained
income for joe
huh
that seems like the sort of thing we
should maybe investigate that's the sort
of thing that i wish we knew about
before the 2020 presidential election
that's the sort of thing that would have
gotten maybe 12 percent of biden's
voters not to vote for him and that's
not even counting all the dead people
who voted for him that's just the living
people who voted for him so that would
have swung the presidential election
without question
what does the white house have they must
have a good explanation right one
they've known about this for a long time
two they're going to just call it
misinformation and republican agitprop
so okay jensaki white house press
secretary how do you explain
all of the
strange joe biden business dealings how
do you explain that one of hunter
biden's business partners came to the
white house to meet with vice president
joe biden during the obama
administration
on hunter biden the new york post is
reporting
looking at white house visitor logs
there were 19 visits to the white house
while the president was vice president
uh by hunter biden's business partner
including one with the vice president
can you help us understand why that
business partner had access and what
those meetings were about
i i don't have any information on that
i'm happy to check and see if with any
more comment
no they don't have any information sorry
whoops this is really damning
it's not like they didn't know about
this this has been a major issue this
has probably been the biggest weakness
for joe biden since before he was
elected president
and everyone knows about it it's on the
white house visitor logs they've known
about this for years
if there were any way to spin this into
anything other than what it obviously is
which is a pay for play corrupt
high-level multi-million dollar
corruption scheme involving
the chinese government involving hostile
foreign powers and joe biden if it were
anything other than that they would have
an excuse and they don't
and so she punts and we're gonna have to
circle back
and then they're just gonna avoid the
question as best they can
such
rank
corruption you already had
joe biden not just on the ropes he was
he was completely underwater to mix
metaphors he's he's losing on the
economy he's losing on inflation he's
losing on immigration he's losing on
foreign policy he's losing on energy
he's losing on covet he's losing on
everything people don't have any
confidence in his ability to govern but
the the one thing that biden
brought
was that he's just a return to normal
he's just good old good old scranton joe
we all we know good old uncle joe
that mean old donald trump he's a crook
he's corrupt he's mean he's he's got a
bad character but joe he's got a really
good character right no
no he doesn't he's
obviously a crook
he's obviously a very corrupt man who
has been in washington way too long and
who has sold out his influence in the
american government to make a quick buck
not just for his kid who made a lot of
quick bucks but apparently for himself
too unless they can come up with any way
to explain 5.2 million dollars unless
they can find out any way to explain 19
visits by hunter biden's business
partner to the white house when when joe
was vice president
and so what do they do
the only thing democrats can do right
now is focus on
donald trump the only thing they can do
is focus on the guy who hasn't been
president in a year and a half chuck
schumer now he was asked a question
about how are we going to deal with
inflation
americans going to the gas pump
americans going grocery store they can't
afford huge surges 40-year highs in
inflation what are you going to do this
is a midterm election year come on chuck
tell me how you're going to fix it
here's his answer blame trump
if you want to get rid of inflation the
only way to do it is to
undo a lot of the trump tax cuts and
raise rates no republican is ever going
to do that so the only way to get rid of
inflation is through reconciliation
the only way to get rid of inflation is
by undoing the tax cuts from five years
ago
that's that's your best
that's your best explanation of the
record high inflation that we're facing
right now is trump did it five years ago
and then it just sort of laid dormant
for
four and a half or five years and then
isn't it just joe's bad luck
that that inflation just sprung up so
the grain of potential hypothetical
truth in what schumer said is
theoretically you could
try to curb inflation by raising taxes
because when you raise taxes you're
taking money away from people and when
you take money away from people they
have less money to spend on consumer
goods and if they have less money to
spend on consumer goods then the demand
will decrease and theoretically maybe
the prices should stop soaring
now the real demand for those goods
won't actually decrease but the ability
of people to pay for them will decrease
so maybe theoretically you could stop
that although a lot of more right-wing
economists would say no actually you
should cut taxes and then this is going
to lead to such a surge in productivity
that you can deal with inflation that
way regardless
it's a completely bogus argument here
from schumer because what are the real
drivers of inflation okay so we got his
his version is its tax cuts from five
years ago here are some maybe some other
uh culprits
um
the democrats insisting on recklessly
printing record levels of money for
years just printing money and giving it
away to people that might be one the
democrats insisting and republicans
acquiescing unfortunately to shutting
down the country for a couple of years
that that might have something to do
with it uh the
the war in ukraine that vladimir
zelinski leader of ukraine admits
uh was caused
especially by joe biden taking the the
sanctions off of vladimir putin's oil
pipeline uh that could be it
the stupid energy policy which is is
making america reliant on foreign oil so
that when wars break out in europe for
instance the oil prices are going to go
through the roof that's going to drive
inflation all of those things would seem
to be more immediate and egregious
culprits of inflation than some tax cuts
five years ago but furthermore
if schumer even wanted to make the tax
cut argument then the argument would be
we need to take money out of the economy
we've got to take that money out of the
economy so people have less money to
spend so that maybe prices will stop
going through the roof so if that's the
case why are democrats pushing to
forgive student loans why are the
democrats on capitol hill and joe biden
pushing to forgive student loans or to
put a pause on student loan payments all
that's going to do is inject more money
into the economy so even by the logic
the really poor logic that schumer's
trying to advance here his argument
fails because at the same time he's
saying we need to take money out of the
economy he's trying to pay off his his
base by saying no we're going to give
you guys young liberal college educated
people with lots of debt we're going to
just give you more money to spend spend
spend spend
not going to do anything
for inflation it's just completely weak
now
what is trump saying about all this
we don't really know because trump's not
back on twitter
i think what we were all hoping for
was elon musk takes twitter
it breaks up the
the lock on conservative speech
the floodgates open we can start talking
about joe biden's corruption we can
start talking about how men aren't women
we can start talking about how we relied
to by the public health authorities for
the past two years we can start talking
about all those things
but what we were really waiting for
were those juicy spicy trump tweets at
least for me i want
i want to see the trump tweets they're
really really funny the man is a poet
i'm not being hyperbolic he is a poet
in the medium of twitter he knows how to
use words in the funniest punchiest way
in that medium and i just want to see
the tweets again the the fake tweet
press releases are not doing it for me i
need the tweets and yet trump has said
he's not going back
to twitter because trump has his own
social media platform called truth
social and not a lot of people are using
it right now but he's gone in and he's
going to stick with that platform and he
doesn't want to reward twitter so he's
not going to go back to them after they
dissed him and kicked him off
okay
i am really sad about this
but for right now it actually might be
the best thing for our country that
trump is not on twitter at this very
moment
because the minute trump gets back on
twitter
everything is going to be about trump
again
and right now the democrats are losing
so badly on every single front and we're
in a midterm election year
i think it would be much better to keep
all the focus on the democrats and all
the focus on joe biden and the failing
democrats on capitol hill
this is a personal sacrifice that i am
willing to make so that the democrats
lose a little bit more of their power in
november
i'm not convinced that trump won't come
back onto twitter before the
presidential election especially if he's
considering running i just bet he's
going to have to go back onto twitter
and then it's going to be about trump
again and some people don't even want
that to happen i sort of think look
he's got every right to run for
president he's my favorite republican
president in my lifetime you're going to
have other candidates out there ron
desantis appears like he is going to be
running for president the leading senate
senator right now who could run would be
ted cruz i think that's pretty clear
maybe josh hawley would run i'm not sure
maybe rand paul i don't know there could
be a lot of people running christie
gnome the governor in south dakota might
run so if we're talking about a primary
situation then i guess everyone should
should put themselves in the best
position they can and duke it out and
figure out who the best candidate is
but for right now there's no political
goal achieved by trump going back onto
twitter other than
other than the sheer delight and humor
of it all but i i suspect that's
something democrats are actually hoping
for because
when your opponent is hanging himself
you should not interrupt
when your opponent is is digging his own
political grave you should not stop him
from doing that and that's what the
democrats are doing right now
speaking of morbid things
and speaking of entertainment for that
matter
there's a clip i have to get to from
megan fox i haven't followed megan fox
very closely i know she's a movie star
she's married to someone named machine
gun kelly i don't know anything about
machine gun kelly the only thing i know
about these two is that they are
very popular entertainers
who are into really weird new age occult
rituals and who drink each other's blood
and they were like oh machine gun kelly
and i like kind of knew the name but
didn't so i'm like machine gun kelly i
like look it up and i was like oh
we're gonna be in so much trouble
because he's literally like my exact
physical type that i've been manifesting
since i was
four i'm also four years older than him
so i think i made him
my thoughts and intentions grew him into
the person that he is who knows what he
would have looked like or been like if
it wasn't for me i guess to drink each
other's blood might
mislead people or like people are
imagining us with like goblets and we're
like game of thrones drinking each
other's blood it's just a few drops
but yes we do consume each other's blood
on occasion for ritual purposes
only
i had gotten to a point where i was like
we need an adrenaline injection of god
in this relationship
and
so we went to costa rica and we had
peruvian shamans who administered the
hiawaska
and um we each went in with different
questions that we wanted the medicine to
answer for us
everyone is making fun of megan kelly
and
negatives no not megyn kelly that would
be the strangest mashup of those two you
have megan fox and machine gun kelly
what do you get megan kelly no not quite
everyone's making fun of megan fox and
machine gun kelly here because they're
saying really weird trippy hippy dippy
new agey things
they are the norm
in human history
when megan fox and machine gun kelly say
that they drink each other's blood and
that megan fox manifested machine gun
kelly manifesting is this new age term
where you think that you can control the
universe by your thoughts you think that
you can bring god into submission and
have him do your will just by thinking
it it's a new age idea it's taking the
true idea that you should think
positively you should have confidence
you should have hope it's taking that
and perverting it and twisting it and
making it
making you believe that you are a god
who can actually control all of the
course of events simply through your own
telepathic powers or something so she
says i i manifested the development of
this man and i turned him into my lover
and for ritualistic purposes we drink
each other's blood
and then we we wanted an infusion of god
in our relationship so we went to peru
and did a bunch of drugs and a weird
shaman gave us a bunch of drugs and we
did the drugs to figure out
our life together and our future and the
universe man
people are making fun of them as
abnormal or weird or kooky they're not
this is the norm this is the norm in
human affairs
the only reason that we are not
accustomed to this stuff though
increasingly we are
is because of monotheism
is because the ancient israelites
told the world about god and they went
through and they
conquered all of the
crazy pagans along their way and they
established themselves in the holy land
and then
a a king and a savior was born to the
jews and he saved the whole world and he
and the light of christ spreads
throughout the world and then even islam
which christians believe is a
just a christian heresy it's just a sort
of misinterpretation of what
christianity is muslims believe that
it's the final revelation of god the
same revelation that was made to the to
the jews and then through christ who
they don't think as a savior but do you
think is a sort of prophet uh
monotheism
says stop drinking each other's blood
stop
taking a bunch of drugs in the in the
desert stop believing that through
shamans and witch doctors you can
control the entire world that's
that's the aberration
that's the abnormal thing in world
history
but when you when you look at the
spanish conquistadors when they came to
to the americas
you saw a bunch of megan foxes and
machine gun kelly's doing weird cult
rituals and drinking each other's blood
and having all sorts of weird sacrifices
and cultic beliefs
when you look at all the tribes in the
middle east
before the advent of monotheism this is
what you saw all of the pagan religions
in the far east that's what you saw
are regressing
okay we are regressing because of the
west's rejection of the religion that
made it which is christianity and
when you when you don't believe in god
when you reject christianity
it's not that you believe in nothing
it's that you believe in everything and
so it is no coincidence that with the
decline of traditional religious
practice in the west you are seeing
simultaneously the rise of really weird
stuff
like the secret or new age or
transgenderism for that matter or also
or the people who love the crystals or
all all of these weird
or astrology or all of these weird
practices because man is a fundamentally
religious being when megan fox says that
she needed an injection of god into her
relationship she's speaking to an actual
human desire we do want something more
we want something more than this
physical world and so how are you going
to fill that you can either fill that
with weird superstitious ultimately
destructive and i think pretty clearly
demonic practices like drinking each
other's blood or you can fill it with
the highest fulfillment of those things
when when christians go to mass
on to your church service on sunday and
take the communion you are taking
you you're taking part in a sacrament
that is
a
uh representation and if you're catholic
you believe a true representation in
that it there is a transubstantiation of
eating flesh and drinking blood it
happens to be eating the flesh and
drinking the blood of your savior
and all the modern atheists liberal
open-minded free-thinking people they
say that's so weird that's so weird
christians oh my gosh i can't believe
that you would do that you think that
you've got this sacrament where you're
eating and drink eating the flesh and
drinking the blood of
god oh my goodness what a crazy thing
hey we're going to go over to peru and
do some ayahuasca with a shaman
because we're normal people we're not
weird like you crazy christians
everybody's got to serve somebody okay
and this is this is why i do often bring
politics back not just to the to the
culture but ultimately to religion and
theology theology is faith seeking
understanding it's not superstition it's
the opposite it's applying rigor and
logic and and reason to the natural
religious longings that people have
because
the more that we reject christianity the
more that these very misguided liberals
reject christianity as
somehow unreasonable though they never
quite explain why it's unreasonable but
they just they have this prejudice
against it and they say oh it's
traditional that's we don't like that
we're gonna get rid of that
we're gonna follow science
with a capital s and a trademark over
the e the more we're going to get really
bizarre kooky superstitious pagan
theories such as
the american academy of pediatrics
which in its new guide on puberty
is discussing girls with erections
that's that's the phrase they've got a
new guide on puberty called u-ology a
puberty guide for everybody
targeted toward children ages 9 through
13 years old explaining how some girls
are actually boys and how girls can get
erections and that's totally normal and
totally fine
and these people have the audacity to
make fun of christians and jews and
muslims as superstitious
that what one thing that this conveys
just on a political point is that you
you really can't trust anything these
modern leftist medical associations have
to say they say you don't believe the
science you don't believe the cdc and
the who and the american pediatric
academy and you know well no if they
think that girls can get erections then
i don't trust anything they say because
they don't understand the most basic
elements of human nature so no i don't
trust them at all i trust a random blog
i read on the internet much more than i
trust these people because these people
are getting something fundamentally
wrong that i know for a fact is
is fundamentally wrong
this is
the kind of weirdness that is going to
enter into your political society
if you reject basic truth we're going
way we are going so far down this path
the the only way out i think is to
try to hold on to some grasp of the
traditions some grasp of reality someone
the other day pointed out that
conservatives they talk about free
speech and this then all they really
want is christian nationalism christian
nationalism is a contradiction i think
it's jen rubin at the washington post
christian nationalism is in many ways a
contradiction in terms because
christianity makes universal claims
lowercase c catholic claims about the
world and so it
christian nationalism is a con
conflicting sort of statement but
regardless okay let's use the phrase
christian what does that mean we
american conservatives want christian
standards and christian traditions in
society and what's the alternative
pumping eight-year-old boys full of
puberty blockers
that's the alternative uh sign me up for
the christian nation please hey where do
i get me some of that christian nation
which do you want if we look back at the
actual
practical application of these things
i think we're beginning to find out that
the people using their unfettered reason
people using they're just they're
inflicting their will on society to undo
everything we've come before that has
come before us
those people are giving us a society
that is unrecognizable and ugly and
something we don't desire and now when
we've got a little free speech we're
allowed to say it and we're allowed to
take our country back i'm michael noel's
just the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire